what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns season a
prediction video before I get started I
just want to give a quick reminder to
those of you that may not have watched
my last video I am doing a new giveaway
since Game of Thrones season 7 comes out
on blu-ray and DVD next month I will be
giving two copies away so there will be
two winners picked randomly all you need
to do is click the link and follow the
instructions you can put your name in
the drawing multiple times that way you
can increase your chances of winning
that link will be posted at the top of
the comment section and it will be in
the description of this video good luck
to everyone who has entered now let's
begin the other day I made a postal and
Twitter & patreon letting everyone know
that I will be doing a new Q&A video and
on those posts I asked you to leave any
questions you might have regarding Game
of Thrones and more specifically Game of
Thrones season 8 I want to thank all of
you for posting your questions and if I
don't happen to answer yours today I
will way insert it in a later video
because I did take screenshots of all
the questions I did see but now I want
to go through some of the ones that I
have here the first question is from
peril wolf do you think Daenerys will
find out that jon is her nephew and if
so what do you think her reaction will
be after all she is not the last
Targaryen I do think that Eris will find
out and she's gonna be shocked just like
anyone else would be when this gets
revealed I think it's gonna cause some
real tension in their relationship
considering John would be the next
rightful heir in line for the throne in
Ogden Aerys this entire time that era
says assumed she had the rightful claim
of where everyone else but now we know
that is not the case but we also all
know how John is and he's not gonna want
to be concerned with sitting on the Iron
Throne I actually wouldn't be surprised
if John just allowed the Narus to have
it assuming Cersei is out of the way in
the end maester aemon also refused to
sit on the Iron Throne when he could
have and I think John may do something
very similar if given the opportunity
maester aemon gave John some wise advice
back in season 1 I think this will come
into play in the last season should ever
come when your Lord father was forced to
choose between honor on the one hand and
those he loves on the other what would
he do
you do whatever was right no matter what
and Lord started unmanned in 10,000
no sir not so strong what is honor
compared to a woman's love what is Duty
against the feel of a newborn son in
Europe or a brother's smile
I believe Daenerys is gonna be pregnant
with John's child so even if John and
Daenerys and their relationship for
political reasons or any other reason I
think John will do the right thing and
make sure that his child is brought up
the way that he would have liked to have
been raised John would never want the
father a bastard he has even said this
himself before because he knows what
that life is like she was up there in
the brothel as ROS took off her clothes
but I couldn't do it because all I could
think was what if I got her pregnant she
had a child another bastard named snow
she's a good life for a child with all
the foreshadowing done during season
seven i 100% believe Daenerys will be
pregnant they hinted at John having
children and they hinted at Daenerys not
being able to have children multiple
times but even John told Daenerys that
maybe marry master was wrong maybe
Daenerys can get pregnant
a full fitted the right to claim his
soul it's yours it serve you well your
children after you
I believe vissarion's death was a
payment for life Dany may have lost a
dragon but she will gain a child like I
said John's gonna want to make sure his
child is not a bastard like him which
means he would need to marry Daenerys or
he could just legitimize the child
himself since he is the king but we will
have to see how this plays out in the
final episodes because John could die in
battle or Daenerys could die in battle
or even during childbirth John and
Daenerys may have a few arguments over
the season but I don't think they're
gonna turn into enemies but that's just
my opinion the next question is from
Mohammed
what's Daario naharis role will be in
the next war I don't think he would just
stay in Mereen when he hear about the
golden company coming to support Cersei
against his love knowing Daario I am
sure he can't wait to leave Marine he
didn't want to stay there in the first
place he doesn't give two shits about
that city there's finally peace in
marine you will keep the peace while the
people choose their own leaders [ __ ]
Murray [ __ ] the people I'm here for you
nothing you promised me my sword is
yours my life is yours but regardless of
what the character might do you have to
consider what the showrunners might do
and as far as I know they have no plans
of bringing Daario back we didn't see
Daario last season and there has been no
sign of him this season either there are
no reports of him coming back nor is
there any photos of him one and he said
I would like to see Daario again and I
know some people have speculated that he
might be with the golden company but
they already casted that commander and
it's not the same guy who
darío they could surprise us and bring
him back but I wouldn't count on it
there are already over 10 characters
still alive that we haven't seen for a
very long time even John's dire wolf was
not seen at all last season and he
should be near John at all times
so personally I wouldn't bet on seeing
Daario again the next question is from
our ex I see racing why did him Robert
kill the Mad King if he was a Targaryen
well we all know Robert would have
killed any Targaryen he got his hands on
he said this himself
Narus Targaryen has we'd some Dothraki
horselord what of it do we send her a
wedding gift knife perhaps a good sharp
one and a bold man to wield it she's
little more than a child well soon
enough that child will spread her legs
and start breeding so men were not
speaking of this oh it's unspeakable to
you what her father did to your family
that was unspeakable what Rhaegar
Targaryen did to your sister the woman I
loved I'll kill every Targaryen I get my
hands on you can't get your hands on
this one Kenya I believe Robert would
have killed the Mad King but the only
problem was Robert didn't get to him in
time to kill him himself
when Robert met Rhaegar Targaryen on the
battlefield at the Trident Robert was
actually injured during his fight
against Rhaegar Robert was able to kill
Rhaegar with his Warhammer but since he
was injured Robert actually had Ned go
to King's Landing first in front of him
while Robert followed when the word got
out that Robert killed Rhaegar Tywin
used that as an opportunity to seize
King's Landing himself and perf his
loyalty to Robert because Tywin knew
Rhaegar was dead and most away Gore's
men had retreated from the war Tywin new
Robin was about the one to throne so
Tywin raced to King's Landing and he got
there before Ned or Robert could when
Tywin got the King's Landing he tricked
the Mad King into letting him into the
city and that's when Tywin ordered his
men to start killing everyone when the
Mad King realized Tywin had tricked him
he knew his time was about to be up so
he ordered the Pyromancer to light the
city on fire with wildfire but Jaime was
there as the mad Kings personal guard
when Jaime knew that Mad King was gonna
blow up the city he killed the Mad King
by stabbing him in the back by the time
Ned got there the Mad King was already
dead and
Robert arrived after Ned the Mad King
would actually blown up the city before
he allowed Robert to get to him and kill
him
but if it wasn't for Jaime that would
have happened that's why Robert wasn't
able to kill the Mad King because Jaime
did it first before he even got there
the next question is from Daniel Bates
do you think Nymeria and ghosts will
share the screen in Winterfell and if so
how soon in a perfect world I would have
Nymeria and ghosts have a litter of pups
to pass on to any future generation of
stark children but that's assuming John
songs or Oreo will even have any
children at all but I think it would be
nice if the Starks were able to get some
more dire wolves at a ghost of Nymeria
mating but that doesn't seem likely
considering the show doesn't want to
spare any expense on direwolf scenes I
do think we will see ghosts again but
not so much for a Nymeria it kind of
seemed like Arya already said her
goodbyes - Nymeria I would be surprised
if we did see her again but I won't rule
it out but everyone was so pissed off we
didn't get to see ghosts I don't see how
they can't include him in the last
season if they leave ghosts out again
there's gonna be an outrage from the
entire community so I think when John
arrives at Winterfell I think they will
at least show them to reunite but I hope
we get to see ghosts rip apart some
White's - the next question is from
promo who do you think will end up
killing the night king and do you think
bran will be involved a lot brain stark
will definitely be involved brain in the
night King will be connected with each
other until one of them dies at the very
least brain can continue to be there
scowl bran should be able to keep an eye
on the army of the Dead and the night
Kings movements with the use of the
Ravens bran can at least let everyone
know where the night king is at all
times and how close he is getting to
them now when it comes to killing the
night king I think that may take a group
effort Jon Daenerys and bran will
probably all play a role in that the
night King is the king of ice and
Daenerys is the queen of fire so I think
those two will face off on the Dragons
very soon but I also think John's gonna
get a one verse one fight against the
night king also John and the night King
have already had two epic stare downs
there needs to be some kind of payoff or
closure to that
[Applause]
[Applause]
john wants to kill the night king so bad
he can taste it and the night king knows
John is very special that's why he keeps
looking at John the way he does those
two need to fight each other
and may the best man win the next
question is from Ed McCluskey for the
amount of screen time given relative to
the book sections left out was there any
point to Thorne's storyline in real
terms to be honest not really I do want
to say one thing though I absolutely
loved Oberyn Martell the actor did such
a great job he made Oberyn one of my
favorite characters of all time but he
didn't serve that much of a purpose
either other than fighting for Tyrians
life and unfortunately he lost
besides Oberyn Martell I didn't like
anything else Doran had to offer in the
show the only other part they really
played was killing Circe's daughter that
way the Maggy the Frog prophecy would be
proven real but I guess you could say
Dorne helped Cersei and Euron form an
alliance with each other since Euron did
use the same snakes as his gift to
Cersei but there was probably other ways
you could have done this
but since Dorne was already introduced
in the show it did give them something
else to do with those characters but I
don't want to spend too much time
beating up Dorne because I feel like
every other channel has already done
this over the years it's kind of like
beating a dead horse at this point but I
just wanted to say that I loved Oberyn
Martell because I was glad they involved
him in the story but everything else I
could have done without to be honest but
that's just my opinion it doesn't make
it fact the next question is from Tom
Hendricks how many episodes will the war
with the night King take slash war for
the throne I'm gonna have to say three
episodes at the most because there was
only six episodes left an HBO hired
three different director to do those
final six episodes we already know Dan
and Dave is gonna write and direct the
final episode but the other five
episodes will be split between Miguel
supports Nick and David Nutter
Miguel supports Nick is best known for
his battle sequences because he directed
hardhome and battle of the bastards and
he will most likely direct the battle
scenes in season 8 - since he is great
at that so I'm thinking he's gonna
direct two episodes at the least but
maybe even three episodes
Miguel should direct a big battle
against the night
in a big battle against Cersei but he
could possibly do one more smaller scale
battle I think the war against the night
king is gonna take more than just one
fight but I think they could end the war
with Cersei with just one episode of
battling but we will see the next
question is from Alex ash will bran
forgive Jaime for pushing him from the
window for all the good Jaime has done I
think when this eventually gets revealed
that Jaime was the one who crippled bran
it's gonna be very interesting because I
think the Starks are all going to feel
very differently about this and about
Jaime
I think Arya would want to kill Jaime
right away and maybe even John would too
but I do think bran would forgive Jaime
when brain was a little boy he always
felt terrible about his injury he was
sad that he would never become a knight
or just be able to do the things his
brothers were doing but now brain looks
at things through a different lens and
he may see all of this as his destiny
things that needed to happen in order
for him to become the three-eyed Raven
and with that in mind he might give
Jaime a pass I do think Jaime still has
a bigger role to play and if you've seen
any of my previous prediction videos
then you should know that I think Jaime
will repay his debt to the Starks by
saving one of their lives the next
question is from Christy do you think
Cersei will forgive bran and send him
after Jaime and if so where do you think
they might meet up
I think bran might seek out Jaime or
Tyrion on his own someone stole over on
a big-ass castle and he's not gonna let
all of his life risking deeds go to
waste
bran put his ass on the line too many
times to just forget about what is owed
to him now that Jaime has left King's
Landing I don't think bran has any
reason to even stay there I don't think
we're gonna be seeing any scenes between
bran and Cersei anytime soon though bran
and Cersei are not allowed to be in the
same scenes with each other because
that's actually a clause in their
contracts
apparently Jerome and Lena dated many
years ago and their relationship ended
pretty badly and now they refuse to work
with each other so I don't know how bran
would ever be able to work with Cersei
unless it was all done through sending
messages back and forth when you
consider that I really don't see any
other scenario that would work in my
opinion bronze gonna go north to but I'm
not really sure when Jaime might try and
find him before he gets too far from
King's Landing
a will answer one more question then I
will save some of these other ones for a
future Q&A video if you would like to
ask any questions put them in a comment
section on this video and the next time
I make one I will come back to this
video and go through some of them but
the last question is from Erin Bergman
do you think we could see Uncle Benjen
in season 8 he seems to be much more
than he seems
and what a shocker it would be if he
suddenly appeared on his horse right
next to the knight King I know I'm alone
but I still think John was let go from
the frozen lake rather than rescued
slash escaped I really love this
question and I actually started to
visualize it as I was reading it the
image of Benjen Stark coming back riding
a dead horse next to the knight King
would be absolutely insane and I would
actually love to see that I think it
would be very cool although I would hate
to see benjin dead but the thought of
that sounds kind of awesome I actually
made a prediction video a while ago and
I kind of talked about this before I
always felt like benjin would come back
and John would actually have to be the
one to kill him John has always loved
his Uncle Benjen in four years he
wondered if his uncle could really still
be alive and out there beyond the wall
somewhere John did finally get to see
his uncle again but the reunion was so
short-lived I think it would be a game
of Thrones esque ending for benjin if he
came back and John actually had to be
the one to kill him
it would be very heartbreaking for a lot
of people but it would need to be done
or else benjin could kill John or any of
the other Starks the reason why I think
this is possible because benjin did die
north of the wall surrounded by whites
and I bet the night king would love to
have a Stark in his army especially one
of the Starks who was a 1st Ranger of
the Nights Watch
the night King lost a lot of his
soldiers when Daenerys started burning
them all with their dragons so he may
have raised benjin start to march in his
army the only problem I have with this
is benjin had dragonglass in his heart
so I'm not really sure how this would
work I always thought it was kind of
weird how the children of the forest
saved benjin by stabbing him with
dragonglass but they also created the
night king the same way so I really
don't know what this would make benjin
right now and I'm not exactly sure how
the whites were gonna be able to kill
him since he was kind of one of them but
feel free to speculate all you want put
all of your questions theories and
thought
down below in the comment section don't
forget to enter the new giveaway if you
want a chance to win Game of Thrones
season 7 on blu-ray or DVD I am giving
two copies away just make sure you click
the link in the comment section or
description of this video I want to
thank everyone for taking the time out
of their day to watch this I really
appreciate that and all of you who have
supported this channel on patreon I hope
everyone has a great day
I'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]